God give me the strength to get through  the next three days please  hallelujah did that today the government  males put initiative to have American  sign something they're calling the  Patriots off the deadline for signing is  the day after Thanksgiving this is not  America that I know Christopher we said  we're not talking politics I'm not gonna  ruin Thanksgiving I promise rest assured  [Music]  okay now politics you treat people who  don't agree with everything you say like  they're more sorry to be the bearer of  bad news  [Music]  [Applause]  I came back against the skies hey I want  it just one more time so I'm I'm really  sorry you got tased I don't know if this  because it's still electricity in my  body but I am  [Music]  you  [Music]  you